the duchess of sussex is helping spread
some Thanksgiving spirit in London this
morning Megan Markel is her name she
visited a community kitchen known as hub
that helps local residents who were hit
by tragedy her contribution to a
best-selling cookbook help fund the
kitchen
Jonathan Vigliotti was there for the
royal visit the women at this kitchen
simply called the duchess megan an
informality that comes from a nearly
year-long bond formed through food the
American royal looked at ease as she
rolled up her sleeves to help her fellow
chefs prepare a salad this morning I
immediately felt connected to this
community kitchen like these women I'm
passionate about food and cooking as a
way of strengthening communities the hub
community kitchen was started in the
summer of 2017 after a massive fire
gutted the Grenfell apartment complex in
West London killing more than 70 people
and leaving hundreds without a home
survivors brought together by tragedy
began healing through cooking using
small donations to stay open twice a
week to cook for victims the Duchess
first visited the kitchen in January
after moving into nearby Kensington
Palace with then-fiance
Prince Harry she described a sense of
belonging which led to an idea a
cookbook called together featuring all
the women's family recipes the proceeds
have allowed the kitchen to be
completely redesigned and refitted and
we'll keep hub open seven days a week
making up to 200 meals a day for senior
homes and homeless shelters give us but
but because we together is already an
international bestseller and has raised
over 260 thousand dollars to help keep
the stoves here hot around the clock
in the shadow of tragedy this American
Duchess has helped bring the spirit of
Thanksgiving to the UK for CBS this
morning Jonathan Vigliotti London
sometimes forget the importance of this
holiday exactly yeah but Megan is a hit
I love what the woman said you know she
gives us power because we feel our love
yeah a lot of people have greater
holiday yes representing the u.s.
wellness right thanks team spirit skips
the pond